in this video you're going to learn how
to graph polom using the zeros the end
behavior the multiplicity of the zeros
and we're going to get a good sketch of
our graph we're going to go through two
examples so let's do the first one
together and the second one you can
practice on your own to kind of test
yourself so this first one we have f ofx
= 2 * x + 4 * x - 1^ 2 * x - 5 Cub now
this is already in factored form if
yours is not in factored form you can
Factor it first and then what you want
want to do is to find the zeros you're
going to set all these factors equal to
zero so the factor is like a group so
you can see here if I go off to the side
and I say oh x + 4 is equal to Z
subtract four from both sides x = -4 so
that means it's going to cross the x
axis here right at -4 now notice that
this only occurs one time you can think
of this as a one here that's like
multiplicity one over here when we set X
- 1 equal to Z you can see we get xal 1
but that's with a multiplicity of two
and we're going to talk about what the
graph looks like when it approaches this
uh x intercept of one and then lastly if
we set x - 5 equal to zero and add five
to both sides you can see that we're
getting X is equal to 5 so that's going
to be right right here on the x axis
okay now before we get into the
multiplicities let's talk about the N
Behavior now the N Behavior tells us
when you go to the right end of the
graph is it going up towards positive
infinity or down towards negative
infinity and when we go to the left end
of the graph is it going up or is it
going down now the way you can determine
that is by this leading coefficient so
the leading coefficient tells us about
the right end behavior so because it's
positive that means this graph is going
to go up towards positive Infinity so
that means it's going to be going like
something like this now if you're not
sure about this what you could do is you
could put in a number let's say for
example like 10 n for x and when you
multiply this out you're going to see
it's going to be a really large positive
number but the shortcut is you look at
the leading coefficient if it's positive
it's going up to the right okay now how
do we know if it's going up to the left
or down to the left well we're going to
look at the degree of this polinomial
now you don't have to multiply this out
that would take quite a bit of time but
what you can see is that one + 2 is 3 +
3 is 6 so what I'm doing is I'm adding
these exponents if I was to multiply
this out this would be an x to the 6th
power so it' be a 6th degree polom when
the degree is even that means it's going
to be going the same direction to the
left as it is going to the right if this
was going down then this one would be
going down so even degree means the same
end behavior right and left if it's an
odd degree it means they're going in
opposite directions and you can check
out a video I did talking about n
Behavior if you want to learn more about
that but now what we want to look at is
what happens when you approach this
point4 well4 this only has a
multiplicity of one when it's an odd
multiplicity it's going to go through
that x intercept and in this case you
can almost think of it as like a line
like x to the 1 is like like a line
right so it goes through like
this now over here at one this has a
multiplicity of two see how it's squared
so you can think of the shape of an X
squ like a parabola so when it's an even
degree what's going to happen is it's
going to bounce off of that point it's
going to basically look like a parabola
like X squ but if this degree is even
like 2 4 6 it's going to bounce it's
going to basically look like that U
shape at that x intercept and then over
here at five we have an odd multiplicity
which tells us that it's going to go uh
through so when it's odd it goes through
now if you want to get a little bit
fancy here you can think about what does
X cubed look like well X cubed the graph
looks like this where it's almost going
to bend and kind of bounce but then it
goes through so it kind of bends the
other direction like this so this is
just a sketch when you get to calculus
you're going to learn about how to find
out exactly how far this graph maybe it
goes way down here or maybe it just goes
down a little bit uh that's kind called
the uh extreme points or the extraa or
where the graph bends but for right now
we're just trying to get a rough sketch
now you can also find this Y intercept
point right here where it crosses the Y
AIS by putting zero in for x and you can
solve for the Y intercept okay but this
gives us a pretty good sketch let's take
a look at another example and we'll
we'll do some
more okay see if you can get a good
sketch of this polinomial F ofx = -3 *
the quantity x + 3 S time the quantity x
- 3 the 3 power so the first thing I
would do is I would set these factors
these groups equal to zero to find our X
intercepts and I think you can probably
see without doing uh too much work here
x + 3al 0 if we subtract 3 x = -3 right
so that's going to be one of our X
intercepts and if we set x - 3 equal to
0 add 3 to both sides X is equal to
posi3 so those are our two x intercepts
now let's look at the end behavior so
you can see that if we were to multiply
this out which I don't recommend because
it takes quite a bit of time right you
would find out that you would have a
leading coefficient of3 and it would be
-3x to the 5th power see how 2 + 3 when
multiply you add the exponents so
basically we're looking at a
polinomial uh that's a fifth degree but
it has that leading coefficient that's
negative now remember the leading
coefficient tells us about the right end
behavior as we go to the right end of
the graph if it's negative that tells us
we're going to be going down towards
negative Infinity if it's positive that
tells us we're going to be going up
towards positive Infinity but the degree
if it's an odd degree that tells us
we're going to go the opposite direction
to the left so for example if this was
going up then we'd be going down to the
left if it's an even degree they go the
same direction either both up or both
down and the way to remember that is uh
take a look at the uh graph X2 when you
graph yal x^2 see how they have the same
n Behavior they're both going up or if
you graph y = x^2 they're both going
down see like that same end behavior
whereas when you graph x cubed which is
an odd degree see how they're going
opposite directions or if you dox cubed
see it look like that
so we can use that as a guide now let's
look at the multiplicities so at -3 this
zero here when we set this factor to
zero we get -3 twice so at -3 this is a
double zero or multiplicity of two and
what happens is when it's an even
multiplicity is it's going to bounce
it's going to look like a parabola like
X squ now depending on the direction if
it's coming from below it's going to
bounce this way it's coming from above
it's going to bounce like that okay now
what happens over here at positive three
when we set this to zero we got positive
three but it was a multiplicity of three
it occurred three times now when it's an
odd multiplicity that tells us it's
going to go through but if you want to
get a little bit uh nicer graph what you
can
do is think about what x cubed looks
like which looks something like this
it's kind of like this graph right here
so it goes almost like it's going to
turn around and then it bends the other
direction now you might be saying Mario
how did you know to bend right here like
why did you maybe not just go up to here
and then go down right and again we
you'll learn about that in calculus this
is just a rough sketch you can get some
additional points like for example if I
put zero in for X I could solve for this
Y intercept you could also plug in one
and two a negative 1 and a negative -2
try to get a little bit uh better graph
but this is a pretty good sketch now if
you want to see more examples about
graphing polinomial follow me over to
that video I did right there and we'll
get some more practice I'll see you over
in that video